TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
We recently updated one
of your favorite courses
on Udacity, Developing
Android Apps.
It's already helped
more than half a million
developers learn to
build Android apps
and has now been updated to
include the very latest changes
in Android and Android
Studio, including
how to use the new
Constraint Layout Editor
and how to use
Firebase JobDispatcher.
To check it out today,
head on over to the post
linked in the description below.
You can now enter the first ever
Google Play Indie Games contest
in Europe until December 31.
The contest will recognize
the best indie talent
in several countries
and offer prizes
that will help you get your
game noticed by industry experts
and gamers worldwide.
Le Monde increased their
subscription conversion by 6%
on Android, thanks to tools
like Google Play Billing.
To learn more from their
director of mobile and product
manager for mobile, check
out the video on the post.
With the latest
release of TensorFlow
you now have preliminary
Windows support,
which allows you to speed
up your TensorFlow training
with any GPU that runs CUDA 8.
Links to the code
are on the post.
How long does it take for
your Firebase Analytics data
to show up?
Well, it's a common
question we get.
So Todd put together this post
to give you all the details.
Google Cloud Platform
is now officially
an IBM Eligible
Public Cloud, which
means you can now run a
wide range of IBM software
[? SKUs ?] on Google Compute
Engine with your existing
licenses.
More info and next
steps are on the post.
Microsoft recently released
an alpha version of PowerShell
that works on both
OS X and Ubuntu.
And we built a .NET core version
of our tools on top of it.
So now your Google
Cloud PowerShell scripts
can work on Mac or
Linux machines as well.
Links to get started
are on the post.
Customer Match helps you engage
valuable holiday customers
as they're searching on Google,
watching videos on YouTube,
and checking
promotions on Gmail.
And we recently
made it even easier
to manage your customer lists.
Details, as usual,
are on the post.
Please subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thank you for watching this
week's episode of "The Dev
Show."
If you'd like to catch some
of our other recent episodes,
they're right here.